IN HISTORY.
>> Bret: PETER DOOCY LIVE IN
WILMINGTON, DELAWARE, THANKS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TRAVELING TO A
HANDFUL OF CRUCIAL BATTLEGROUND
STATES IN ORDER TO TAKE SOME OF
THE ATTENTION AWAY FROM THE
DEMOCRATS.
THE PRESIDENT IS IN WISCONSIN
RIGHT NOW, CHIEF WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT JOHN ROBERTS HAS
THAT STORY TONIGHT.
>> GOOD EVENING TO YOU,
TRADITION LONG HELD AT THE
OPPOSING CAMPAIGN GOES DARK FOR
THE WEEK THAT THE PARTY HAS IT
PENSION -- CONVENTION, WENT OUT
THE WINDOW IN 2016 AND BEGIN
THIS YEAR AN INDICATION OF HOW
HIGH THE STAKES ARE FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> 78 DAYS, WE ARE GOING TO WIN
THE STATES AND TAKE BACK THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> SO NOT TO CREATE CRITICISM
WITH THE MEGA EVENTS IN 2016,
THE AUDIENCE MAY HAVE BEEN
SMALLER THAN FOUR YEARS AGO, BUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S APPEARANCES
WERE EVERY BIT POLITICAL
RALLIES.
BECAUSE THIS WILL BE THE MOST
IMPORTANT ELECTION IN THE
HISTORY OF THE COUNTRY.
>> IN MANKATO, MINNEAPOLIS, AND
OSHKOSH, OUT AND ABOUT WHILE
JOE BIDEN’S AT HOME PREPARING
AND CONTRASTING HIS POLICIES TO
MAINTAIN LAW AND ORDER WITH
DEMOCRATIC CALLS TO DEFUND THE
POLICE.
>> AS PRESIDENT, MY GOAL TO
RESTORE SAFETY TO OUR STREETS,
BY CONTRAST OF DEMOCRATS THAT
ARE PROMISING TO ELEVATE THEIR
LEFT-WING -- WAR ON COPS AND GO
BACK TO THE WHITE HOUSE IN THE
FORM OF SLEEPY JOE BIDEN.
>> M ON THE ECONOMY COMMENTING
TO GDP WITH $4 TRILLION IN TAX
INCREASES, PRESIDENT TRUMP
PROMISING US WITH BOUNCE BACK
FROM THE CORONAVIRUS, INSISTING
HIS POLICIES WILL LEAD TO A FULL
RECOVERY.
>> THAT IS GOD TESTING MEAN, YOU
KNOW, YOU DID IT ONCE, AND THEY
SAID DO IT I DO A GREAT JOB, I’M
THE ONLY ONE WHO CAN DO IT?
HE SAID, YOU SHOULDN’T SAY THAT,
WE WILL HAVE YOU DO IT AGAIN.
>> DENYING DEMOCRATIC CHARGES HE
IS HOBBLING THE POST OFFICE TO
STOP MASSIVE MAIL-IN VOTING.
TO >> THE POST OFFICE HAS BEEN A
DISASTER FOR MANY DECADES, WE
WANT TO MAKE IT A GOOD
INFLUENCE.
TO $78 BILLION OVER A RELATIVELY
SHORT NUMBER OF YEARS.
IF YOU LOOK AT, AMAZON AND ALL
THESE COMPANIES -- IT’S A WHOLE
NEW BUSINESS, THEY JUST DROP A
LOT RIGHT INTO THE POST OFFICE
AND WE LOSE TWO AND $3 EVERY
TIME WE DELIVER A PACKAGE.
>> THE PRESIDENT REPEATING HIS
FAVORITE MEME ON JOE BIDEN
PORTRAYING HIM AS AN UNWEIGHTED
PUPPET OF THE FAR LEFT, AND
TEXTING PROGRESSIVES, LIKENING
THEM TO FASCISTS.
>> REPLACING AMERICAN FREEDOM
WITH LEFT-WING FASCISM.
WE ARE GOING LEFT ALL THE WAY.
FASCISTS, THEY ARE FASCISTS.
TO SOME OF THEM, NOT ALL OF
THEM, BUT SOME OF THEM, THEY ARE
GETTING CLOSER AND CLOSER.
WE HAVE TO WIN THE ELECTION.
>> IN 2016, WINNING WISCONSIN
AND LOST MINNESOTA BY 1.5
POINTS, JOE BIDEN LEADING IN
BOTH OF THOSE DATES.
BUT THE POLLS ARE BEGINNING TO
CLOSE.
THE PRESIDENT IS OFF TO ARIZONA
TOMORROW WHICH DEMOCRATS ARE
EAGER TO FLIP AND THEN
PENNSYLVANIA ON THURSDAY.
DETERMINING DURING THE
DEMOCRATIC CONVENTION NOT TO LET
A NEW SINGLE NEWS CYCLE GO